k
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
todos muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live da comunidade
fechada como é de pracha vou responder
as dúvidas e a gente depois vai partir
para dois artigos que eu separei aqui
Carlos kman Boa noite José Eduardo
Barros aliás Ramos Boa noite
também como é que está o áudio Carlos e
José me digam Como tá o áudio pra gente
poder prosseguir aqui
eu tava vendo por alto aí os comentários
do grupo do WhatsApp e vi que vocês
estavam comentando sobre a ia da Meta né
eu conheço essa ia da Meta entre as ias
aí que não
são de código fechado né que é o caso do
da Open né o Chef GPT o da e o da
e o cloud né o o clou da
antropic esse Lhama é um dos melhores
que eu conheço é um dos melhores que eu
conheço nunca testei dentro do WhatsApp
não José edard tá dizendo que está ótimo
o áudio então vamos prosseguir aqui bem
Vamos responder as dúvidas de vocês
aqui primeira ah deixa eu só dividir a
tela para mostrar as perguntas
só tem que achar aqui o
formulário e d só um instante
ok aqui configurações respostas
individual deixa eu ampliar a tela ah
mas aqui vai ficar ruim V ampliar de
outro jeito
pronto vamos começar
aqui primeira pergunta do Carlos kman
existe modos de tratar melhorar a bainha
de mielina eu acho que até você já
pesquisou isso no Lhama 3.2 dentro do
WhatsApp né bem só explicando a todos o
que que é bainha de mielina é um
revestimento protetor a redor dos nervos
que ajuda a transmitir os sinais
nervosos é como se fosse um encapamento
do neurônio assim como tem um
encapamento para fio elétrico para
eletricidade ficar dentro do fio e não
perder energia eh tanta energia para
fora então bainha de Melina é parecido
ele ele é tipo um isolante que permite
que o sinal elétrico passe melhor Ok
então quando a bainha AD Melina é
danificada isso ocorre em várias doenças
como esclerose múltipla milite
transversa os sinais elétricos né vão se
perder e aí você vai ter problemas nessa
transmissão Então os sintomas podem ser
variados dependendo da doença pode ser
dor fraqueza muscular perda de
coordenação motora problema de visão
então tem várias abordagens para
melhorar a bainha de
mielina primeiro é muito importante você
tratar doença de base né Se for uma
esclerose múltipla por exemplo você vai
tratar com vitamina D em altas dosagens
né protocolo Coimbra geralmente funciona
bem uns 80% dos pacientes fazendo o
protocolo Coimbra vão reverter esclerose
múltipla e os que não responderem pode
usar cortices
imunossupressores ou até mesmo utilizar
a os os anticorpos clonais então fora
essa questão do tratamento ortodoxo você
pode fazer uma fisioterapia motora para
ajudar a manter a força muscular dessa
pessoa que tá com problema na bainha de
Melina melhorar a coordenação motora né
para melhorar a qualidade de vida então
o corpo tem sim capacidade de reparar a
bainha de mielina e esse processo pode
ser afetado pelo envelhecimento então
tem estudos recentes interessantes
falando que certos genes como grp 17
rato pato grp 17 esses gênes podem
desempenhar funções importantes um papel
crucial no reparo da mielina e tem
moléculas específicas podem ajudar a
melhorar esse processo indivíduos mais
velhos em termos de abordagem
integrativas e naturais você pode
utilizar uma dieta rica em nutrientes
especialmente gorduras de qualidade
ômega3
ômega-9 o ômega 6 GL né o gama
linolênico vitam
Complexo B substâncias antioxidantes
como é o caso da Santina zeaxantina
luteína tudo isso pode ser benéfico
então Além disso o estresse crônico tem
que ser gerenciado tem que fazer
meditação tem que ter um sono adequado
Porque isso pode afetar negativamente o
sistema imune e o reparo da mielina
então é importante também mencionar que
o estilo de vida atividade física
regular o sono adqu que eu já falei
redução de estress tudo isso é muito
importante então Então temos que
combinar todas as estratégias aí para
melhorar a Bain de Melina sendo que a
principal delas já falei né são gorduras
saudáveis que você deve acrescentar na
sua dieta a próxima pergunta Doutor o
exame de biorressonância quântica aos
mods do que postei no grupo Esse eu não
vi esse vídeo Tá mas eu vou dar minha
opinião sobre exames quânticos de modo
geral é um exame confiável para
diagnóstico e tratamento de enfermidades
caso positivo Porque que o o Conselho
Federal de Medicina não reconhece bem
vamos lá primeiro e é muito comum que
essas empresas que representam esses
equipamentos antes disso deixa eu dar
uma boa noite aqui pra Miriam e pra
Estela Mares beijo para vocês duas tá
essas empresas tipo a nova ciência eles
não TM um digamos assim um uma
preocupação de publicar estudo
científico já Participei de um monte de
congresso da nova ciência da Quantum Bio
da
fisioquantic infelizmente esse pessoal
eles gostam de lançar produto mas não
gostam de fazer ciência então eles pegam
os artigos genéricos aí que foram
publicados no exterior e que não é sobre
os produtos deles e usam esses artigos
para justificar que o produto deles
funciona então isso é uma coisa que eu
questiono muito Eu não me sinto
confortável trabalhando com coisas
quânticas tem muita gente que fala muito
bem desses aparelhos tem muita gente que
inclusive de amigas minhas que eu
utilizo no consultório Eu não me sinto à
vontade de fazer uso desses equipamentos
eh eu acredito que pode ter beneficiado
várias pessoas só que no meu caso eu sou
a minha origem é uma origem de ser um
profissional mais cético né eu saí do
ceticismo há 10 anos atrás quando eu fui
trabalhar com a medicina funcional
integrativa mas tudo que eu faço no
consultório é baseado em ciência e essa
ciência é ela tá publicada e não é o
caso por exemplo desses equipamentos
quânticos Ok então eu sinceramente eu
não utilizaria na minha clínica agora eu
não quero dizer com isso que vocês não
possam procurar um profissional que
trabalha com esses equipamentos e ter a
sua própria experiência Ok então eu já
fiz curso de radiestesia eu já fiz curso
de kinesiologia médica Eu sempre tenho
muita dificuldade de aplicar essas
coisas no consultório quando eu vejo que
tem
uma ciência sólida por trás tá Então
essa é minha opinião e o Conselho
Federal de Medicina nunca vai aprovar
realmente uma coisa que não tem ciência
sólida né a exceção seria o caso ozônio
ozônio tem ciência sólida e eles não
reconhecem a ciência do ozônio mas nesse
caso eu tenho que concordar com o cfm
porque eu nunca vi um artigo bacana
realmente falando desses equipamentos
quânticos
Ok próxima pergunta aqui do thgo
tem algum problema de mulher jovem usar
o Wide yem que seria o Yam selvagem né
diariamente e parar apenas nos dias de
menstruação para diminuir S de DPM acne
e etc minha esposa estava usando
anticoncepcional para controlar Tais
sintomas mas ela parou agora e começou a
utilizar eu acho que é uma boa sim é uma
boa sim
tá então a espécie do Yum Cream Wild Yum
Cream que é o Yum bravo né raiz de Yum
bravo é o de osca vilosa né E tem outras
plantas outros fitoterápicos também tem
esse efeito parecido o caso vitex agnos
castos é um que eu gosto de usar
bastante né Então essas plantas são
conhecidas por ter propriedades
antiinflamatórias e equilibram os
hormônios então
você pode usar esse creme de Yum Cream
né Wild Yum
Cream para controlar esses sintomas o
uso do desse produto geralmente é
considerado seguro não tem muita ciência
por trás mas eu já tive alguma
experiência pessoal e vi que
funciona vai demorar uns dias pro creme
fazer efeito não é imediato
Ok se não funcionar sozinho pode
utilizar também o
agnos castos tá que é uma ótima opção
também pode usar também o black cor roch
outra opção E tem também o Angelica
censes são essas três plantas principais
aí para controlar sintomas de TPM que é
causado por oscilação dos níveis de
estrogênio ok também tem uma dieta
equilibrada rica em frutas vegetais
grãos integrais exercícios regulares
Sona adequado tudo isso que já a gente
tá cansado de falar aqui né meditação
yoga tá xuando
mindfulness ômega3 ômega 6 ômega-9
vitamina B6 o óleo de borragem né que é
um tipo de fonte de Gá né de Gam
linolênico óleo de borage ou óleo de
prímula pode utilizar vai ajudar também
na TPM tá
bom homem de 69 anos pergunta da Marilda
com hiperplasia prostática descartada
hipótese de displasia displasia quer
dizer como câncer o câncer é neoplasia
tá não é displasia não consumindo do
homo que é a doxazosina mesilato
doxazosina referia pouca pressão para
urinar pela manhã e dificuldade para
reter a urina durante o dia acrescentou
toda lafila melhorou bem pouca pressão
para urinar pela manhã acrescentou sal
palmeto
óleos também de abóbora e quercetina que
deve ser el colocou quercina mas deve
ser quercetina Melhorou a dificuldade
para reter o ur in mas a pouca pressão
para urinar pela manhã continua e
reclama dor na uretra o que que eu
sugiro sugiro que faça uma investigação
mais abrangente para ver se não tem uma
outra causa pra obstrução infravesical
às vezes temos uretra Às vezes tem um
problema no colo da bexiga de
estreitamento
ok Você falou aqui que além de tá
utilizando o do homo já tava usando
lafila também
era para ter melhorado mais né então tem
que investigar melhor isso aí tá tem que
passar com o médico
investigar Pode ser que seja necessário
nesse caso entrar com um bloqueador de 5
Alfa redut como finasterida doida que eu
não gosto de usar mas alguns casos Eu
uso mas tem que investigar outras causas
para esse problema tá de
obstrução pode ser uma prostatite oculta
também de repente é um prostatite
precisa tratar com antibiótico
antiinflamatório Então tem que fazer uma
avaliação mais abrangente tá se caso ele
queira passar comigo eu tô à disposição
tá próxima pergunta Antônio Renato D
Alan um caso hipotético pergunto não
porque tem acontecido mas porque o
Brasil é um país de pessoas responsáveis
de uma pessoa comprar um alimento como
salgado Coxinha etc e o alimento tiver
sido contaminado com sangue contaminado
com
aides por exemplo quanto tempo o vírus
continua vivo no alimento e o
micro-ondas mata vírus e bactéria ess a
pessoa desconfiar de contaminação de
sangue contaminado se tomar água com
limão depois só por precaução ácido
limão mata o vírus esse vírus Ele é
muito frágil com temperatura tá eu acho
muito muito muito muito muito muito
muito muito improvável que alguém com
aides vai se sangrar na hora de estar
fazendo uma coxinha entendeu E você vai
pegar isso comendo tá até porque o aço
no estômago vai destruir o vírus Mas
enfim
enfim esquente no micro-ondas o alimento
vai perder algumas propriedades né de
nutrientes tem a questão do micro-ondas
muita gente fala que ele é maléfico Mas
pode esquentar no
micro-ondas já vai eliminar totalmente
ess essa situação
Tá além do vírus do HIV ser muito é
frágil com temperatura ele não sobrevive
muito tempo fora do corpo humano tá em
contato com ar ele mhe rapidamente
também vamos pra próxima aqui Antônio
Renato pessoa com vitamina D de 38 no
sangue pode
tomar 1000 15.000 unidades de vitamina D
A unido a 150 MG de K2 durante quantos
meses a cápsula deve ser oriosa aí
Faltou um ponto aí né durante quantos
meses ponto né ou ponto de interrogação
a cápsula deve ser oleosa ou basta tomar
com óleo saudável não não é necessário
que a cápsula seja oleosa se você
ingerir a vitamina D junto com gordura
saudável tá
só tem que tomar cuidado se você tomar
muito tempo 15.000 por dia pode ser que
você entre uma hipervitaminose D
tá tomar cuidado só com
isso próxima pergunta se uma pessoa
estiver com artérias entupidas se tomar
K2 ela desentope evitando infarto AVC
Não é bem assim Antônio não vai ter esse
efeito super rápido não vai demorar uns
2 anos junto com o natoquinase
picnogenol para ter esse efeito tá o K2
junto com a vitamina D ele tem qual
função ele ajuda a equilibrar o o
metabolismo no cálcio você para isso tá
por isso que toma-se junto não é
obrigado a tomar junto não além de
auxiliar na vitamina D o K2 também
previne entupimento de artérias urino de
alimentação nunca deve-se compensar ma
alimentação com Suplementos vou repetir
Nunca se deve
compensar maus hábitos com suplementos
Ok não entra nessa
Ok então você sabe que K2 mk7 ajuda a
direcionar o cálcio pros ossos e dentes
Não deixa esse cálcio aí parar na parede
da artéria ou se acumular em tecidos
moles isso pode ajudar a prevenir a
formação de placas né mas geralmente
para desfazer a placa você tem que
associar junto o anato kinase e o
picnogenol e usar aí pelo menos uns 2
anos
tá lembrando que a vitamina C também vai
ser útil pra saúde arterial os
arginina citrulina os os outros e F terá
que aumentam ag Genina e
citrulina magnésio vai ajudar também tá
lembrando que tem outras coisas que vão
ajudar na saúde
cardiovascular próxima
pergunta não deixou o nome ou o
espermatozoide pode ficar vivo no
Sabonete ou no vaso isso pode causar
gravidez não não vai ocasionar gravidez
porque o spermatozoid tem uma vida muito
curta fora do cor corpo tá ainda mais
quando tem contato com sabonete né que
vai ser uma uma substância alcalina isso
aí vai impedir que esse espermatozoide
sobreviva
tá esa aí que o negócio pulou
aqui ok
então não esquenta a cabeça com isso
isso aí é altamente altamente Provável
não é impossível você engravidar porque
alguém colocou espermatozoide
no Sabonete
tá próxima pergunta também sem nome
pessoa jovem diagnosticada com distimia
e transtorno de ansiedade tem síndrome
das pernas inquietas movimenta os braços
involuntariamente sorri sozinho mas tem
plena Lucidez sabe o que faz e quando
percebe que está sendo observado para de
fazer mas eh tá tá confuso isso aqui né
porque essa pessoa tem S das pernas
inquietas e fica movimentando os braços
e sorrir sozinho isso aqui não dá para
responder facilmente não viu eu não tô
achando que tem nada a ver é a cim das
pernas inquietas é raramente afeta os
braços tá
provavelmente essa pessoa tem outros
problemas eh psiquiátricos
Ok mas falando do ensino de pernas
inquietas tem que investigar se não tá
com deficiência de Ferro né que é uma
das causas
principais uso de antipsicóticos e
antidepressivos podem também provocar a
cimma das pernas inquietas né Então tem
que ver se se a pessoa não tem algum
problema psiquiátrico não tá usando o
remédio
psiquiátrico Ok então tem que investigar
bem aí com um
psiquiatra após tomar comprimido de
berberina na boca tomar comprimido na
boca É ficou meio redundante isso daí né
posso ingerir junto com água com limão
misturado com vinagre de maçã você quer
misturar berberina água com limão e
vinagre de
maçã poder pode se não tiver atacando o
seu estômago não der queimação de
estômago porque a beberina pode em
alguns casos causar irritação intestinal
então se você utilizar os três juntos é
é provável que você tenha alguma
queimação Mas se não tiver você pode
utilizar sim
tá mas eu tomaria separado eu tomaria
água com limão e vinagre e depois eu
tomaria beberina não sei porque que você
tá querendo tomar junto é por causa do
horário é isso mas Experimenta se você
não tiver queimação não tô vendo maiores
problemas
não 500 mg Marina é seguro para
prevenção e Limpeza do Fígado sim é
seguro diariamente 60 dias por exemplo
sim a história do Titanic conta que mais
ou menos 1500 pessoas morreram devido à
água gelada do Oceano houve entretanto
um homem que no momento que o Titanic
bateu no iceberg estava bebendo alguma
bida alcoólica que eu não sei qual é
devido a bebida no seu corpo ficou
aquecido durante algumas
horas olha vida alcoólica não esse corpo
não tá e por causa na verdade o
o pessoal que mora em país frio tipo
Rússia Eles bebem muito vodica né e a
vodica dá uma sensação de conforto para
eles mas o que eu sei sobre isso é que a
bebida não vai aquecer de verdade o
corpo é só uma sensação tá de para
aliviar o o desconforto do frio e por
causa disso a água gelada do Oceano não
matou ele sobreviveu
por curiosidade haveria algum suplemento
para consumir no lugar da vida alcoólica
a fim de manter o corpo aquecido durante
horas o motivo da pergunta é porque pode
ser o caso de consumir suplemento ao
viajar para países muito frios rapaz que
pergunta curiosa
não que pergunta curiosa eu vou dar uma
olhada melhor nessa questão aí do do
álcool mas Até onde eu sei o álcool ele
não tem esse efeito de aquecer o corpo
não
tá mas eu vou checar depois isso melhor
e não conheço nenhum suplemento que
aquece o corpo não
Ah sim agora lembrei de uma coisa o Gin
zeng siberiano né que o pessoal usa na
Sibéria que faz parte da Rússia ele tem
um efeito de aquecimento do corpo tá
então se fosse falar de uma de um de um
suplemento poderia ser o ginseng
siberiano tá e a cafeína como também é
um uma substância também que
aumenta a frequência cardíaca pode
ajudar também a aumentar um pouco a
temperatura corporal né Ele é utilizado
como eh substância pré-treino né para
aumentar a queima de caloria né então
ela pode ajudar nesse
caso Vamos fazer vamos ver a próxima
pergunta
aqui magnésio malato seguro para
prevenção
tem que ser alimentar não alimentar é
deixa eu explicar o conceito para você o
magnésio é o mineral certo como o
mineral ele é uma molécula pequena
quando você junta o magnésio com o
aminoácido por exemplo o de malato né
que são duas moléculas lá de ácido
málico junto ou você junta por exemplo
com treonato ou quando você junta com
glicina a molécula aumenta muito de
tamanho certo quando você consome
magnésio você tem que come consumir
aproximadamente 200 gr do elementar por
dia tá não é que você tem que tomar um
magnésio de malato elementar isso não
existe o magnésio de malato de malato
treonato treonato ou glicina ou glicina
a questão é que você tem que ver quanto
desse suplemento equivale a 200 mg do
magnésio elementar tá isso é uma
continha de física de física não de
química
desculpa geralmente nas embalagens dos
Suplementos tá escrito isso tá
Ahã na pergunta acima eu falei numa
situação hipotética em que uma pessoa
intencionalmente coloca sangue
contaminado no alimento para fazer o mal
Caramba meu Será que alguém já fez isso
e o sangue ainda está fresco Olha acho
muito Improvável isso viu
viu muito muito muito Improvável porque
assim a pessoa vai injetar o sangue
dentro da coxinha isso só o calor da
coxinha já vai meio que matar o vírus né
mas o caso você Esquenta na no
micro-ondas seria esse o o caminho
né mas como eu te falei também destruído
por enzimas digestivas né pelo ácido
estômago tá
Então se uma pessoa toma beberina com e
após alguns minutos tomar limão e
vinagre de maçã ou limão e vinagre de
maçã tira o efeito não não tira o efeito
é só que pode dar queimação no estômago
tá
bom vamos lá vamos ver se temos ao
vivo
amia quando tomo chá termogênico sinto
que meu corpo aquece isso termogênico é
o termo que eu tava buscando até esqueci
então a cafeína hemogênica o jinzen
siberiano também é hemogênico né até a
crina teica hemogênica Então pode ajudar
no frio isso aí
tá sim mas a niacina Estela Mares ela dá
um vermelhão e dá uma sensação de calor
mas ela causa vaso dilatação tá E essa
vasodilatação vai fazer perder calor
Então não é uma boa zacina para aquecer
o corpo não tá porque incl Inclusive eu
já tomei nacina várias vezes em altas
doses eu ficava todo quente assim e uma
hora depois eu ficava frio por quê
Porque você perdia calor por causa da
vaso
dilatação então a ingestão do sangue
contaminado não necessariamente vai
contaminar a
pessoa não porque o o o ácido estômago
pode destruir o vírus facilmente tá mas
se você aquecer no microndas também vai
ter esse efeito também o ácido limão
pode eliminar o vírus eu é não é o ácio
estômago mesmo tá considerando que você
tá engolindo né o alimento né não tem
necessidade de jogar limão em cima não
para matar o vírus não é uma situação
muito sabe peculiar essa que você tá
falando né e eu acho que não tem nenhuns
casos registrado de alguém que pegou HIV
comendo coxinha certo o hord de cártamo
é
termogênico não não é termogênico não
que eu saiba não
tá não é tem gênico bem Vamos aos
artigos né pessoal ou vocês tem mais
perguntas
aí tá Vamos aos artigos se tiver mais
perguntas a gente volta aqui bem eu
queria falar para vocês de um tema que
afeta milhões de pessoas como a
melatonina né que vocês bem conhecem né
muito famoso por ser o hormônio do Sono
poderia melhorar a qualidade do Sono
Isso é meio Óbvio né Mas sai um artigo
interessante
falando das melhores doses
tá o melhor horário então esse artigo é
que eu vou discutir com
vocês Então nesse estudo os
pesquisadores
analisaram os efeitos da suplementação
de melatonina no tempo que leva para
adormecer que é conhecido como latência
do sono e na duração total do sono então
foram examinados 26 ensaios clínicos
então um estudo
randomizado e também um estudo de
metanálise né que foram juntados aí 26
artigos que incluíram um total de
1689 adultos bastante gente né com
idades que variaram entre 23 e 73
anos os participantes receberam dos
melatonina que variaram de 0,1
MG perdão alguma coisa engou na
minha garganta aqui os participantes
receberam dos de melatonina que variaram
entre 0,1 a 10 mg por dia administrados
de 0 a 3,5 horas antes de
dormir a maioria dos estudos utilizou a
forma de liberação rápida de melatonina
eu não uso essa liberação essa forma de
liberação aqui no consultório eu uso
aquela mista né que tem rápida e tem
lenta mas também nesse estudo foram
avaliadas outras formulações como Pets
na pele n estão aplicados sobre a pele e
nas gengivas né
então recapitulando foram
1689 adultos todos com 18 anos ou mais a
idade variou entre 23 A 73 anos abrangeu
bastante idades Diferentes né desses
estudos que foram incluídos na
metanálise três
foram de pessoas sem condições de saúde
relacionadas ao sono enquanto nove
estudos focaram indivíduos com insônia
primária ou seja insônia Sem Causa
aparente Além disso dois estudos
incluíram participantes tanto com ou sem
insônia tá então teve dois estos que
tiveram tanto pessoas com insônia ou com
sem insônia
então isso permiti uma análise mais
abrangente dos efeitos da in Então os
pesquisadores realizaram uma meta
análise de 26 ensaios clínicos
randomizados os participantes receberam
melatonina ou Placebo que é a pila de
farinha por um período que variou de 1 a
28 dias as doses administradas variaram
de 0,1 a 10 mg tomados de 0 a 3,5 horas
antes de
dormir
e comparado ao Placebo melatonina
reduziu tempo necessário para em média 9
minutos ok reduziu o tempo necessário
para adorer em 9 minutos essa redução
foi mais pronunciada com doses entre 3 e
4 mg tomada cerca de 3 horas antes
dormir então a dose que foi mais
interessante foi entre 3 e 4 mg e tomado
3 horas antes de dormir então eu já
tinha mudado minha prática e pedido o
pessoal tomar melatonina um pouco mais
cedo então de forma interessante os
efeitos foram mais significativos em
pessoas sem insônia e quando a
melatonina foi administrada du a 3 horas
antes de dormir tá então foi mais
efetivo para quem não tinha insônia
no entanto é importante notar que houve
indícios de viés de publicação né O que
pode reduzir a confiança desses achados
então a melatonina Aumentou a duração
total do Sono além de tornar o sono mais
rápido para pegar né 9 minutos em
média também aumentou o tempo de duração
do
sono então o pessoal que tomou
melatonina em média dormiu 20 minutos a
mais do que com
Placebo as doses de até 3 MG mostraram
maior eficácia com 3 MG tendo o efeito
mais robusto então 3 MG foi a dose que
eles acharam melhor tá assim como na
latência do Sono a administração de
melatonina 3 A 3,5 horas antes de dormir
apresentou os melhores resultados na
duração do Sono ou seja se forem tomar
melatonina tomem 3 horas antes de dormir
por volta de 3 MG tá isso sugere que o
timing é crucial para maximizar os
efeitos da melatonina ok nós sabemos que
problemas para adormecer ou manter o
sono são extremamente comuns né
praticamente 80% dos meos pacientes TM
problema de sono
afera afeta cerca de 1/3 dos adultos nos
Estados Unidos 1/3 dos adultos nos
Estados Unidos Olha como a quanidade de
gente com problema de sono embora
terapias como a terapia cognitiva
comportamental para insônia sejam
altamente eficazes elas podem ser menos
acessíveis e difíceis de seguir para
algumas
pessoas a melatonina Pode surgir como
uma alternativa viável com poucos
efeitos colaterais relatados mesmo em
doses mais altas estudos anteriores
também corroboraram que a melatonina
melhora a latência e a duração do sono
com efeitos similares aos encontrados na
metanálise que nós estamos discutindo
aqui além disso melatonina não apresenta
dependência ou tolerância nem sintomas
de abstinência quando interrompida isso
torna bastante seguro e conveniente o
uso dela né para longo
prazo e isso foi demonstrado também por
estudos que durou duraram a até 6 meses
com uso de melatonina no entanto alguns
efeitos colaterais leves podem aparecer
como sonolência de urna tontura
e dores de cabeça né isso pode acontecer
sendo recomendado evitar atividades que
exige atenção como dirigir após ingestão
de melatonina Eu acho que eu falei com
vocês aqui porque alguém comentou dar
uma live que a lucier fez com betet que
ela ficou falando que melatonina dá isso
D aquilo outro dá um monte de problema e
eu comentei que eu acho que ela exagerou
na nas orientações dela sobre os efeitos
colaterais da melatonina e eu falei
gente tem muito profissional de saúde
que gosta de ficar trabalhando com
filigrana para mostrar Teoricamente que
sabe mais que o outro eu não tô acusando
a Luci quer de nada eu gosto dela minha
amiga pessoal tá só que o pessoal tem
que ficar meio atento com essas coisas
aí de gente colocando eh
pelo em casca de ovo tá e a lucier tem
umas coisas nela que às vezes eu fico um
pouco preocupado assim sabe apesar de de
eu confiar que ela é uma profissional
excelente então considerações finais
desse estudo melatonina pode ser uma
ferramenta eficaz para melhorar a
qualidade do Sono Especialmente quando
usar nas doses e horários adequados
então de novo 3 horas antes de dormir 3
A 4 mg tá Esse é o melhor esquema para
usar melatonina segundo esta
metanálise vai proporcionar os melhores
resultados em termos de reduzir o tempo
para adormecer aumentar a duração do
Sono
Ok interessante por cas dessa história
das 3 horas antes
Aqui tem uma pergunta do Eliseu que se a
pessoa for afetada pela sepse ao fazer
cirurgia
de amputação o tratamento de
medicina funcional integrativa consegue
curar infecção generalizada efetivamente
eu não sei que tratamente esse tá
falando Eliseu Mas uma pessoa com
infecção precisa tomar antibiótico o que
dá para fazer além do antibiótico que
funciona muito bem é peróxido hidrogênio
endovenoso ou vitamina C em altas doses
endovenoso que tem efeito Ah também mas
isso nem é bem medicina funcional é mais
ortomolecular
pouquíssimos hospitais aceita fazer
vitamina C ou peróxido hidrogênio
endovenoso durante uma sepse mas Poderia
ajudar bastante tá bem o próximo
artigo é sobre exercícios físicos Ok é
muito comum né ouo todo dia no
consultório que as pessoas têm
dificuldade de manter uma rotina de
exercícios porque acha chato né então
saiu um estudo interessante que mostrou
que tá a intensidade do exercício de
acordo com que te dá prazer pode ser a
chave para melhorar a Adesão né e a
pessoa ficar fazendo exercício com
frequência Então vamos entender o
resultado de um estudo recente que
mostra como é que essa abordagem pode
fazer diferença Então nesse estudo os
pesquisadores investigaram se a Adesão a
um programa de exercícios melhora quando
a intensidade dos treinos é regulada com
base no prazer e na tolerância dos
participantes então foram conduzidos em
saios controlados randomizados onde
Metade dos participantes ajustou a
intensidade dos exercícios conforme seu
nível de prazer e quanto a outra metade
recebeu instruções padronizadas para a
intensidade dos treinos ou seja uma
parte foi deixado que regulasse conforme
prazer e a outra parte teve que seguir
uma rotina
padronizada então o objetivo principal
era medir a frequência de participação
nas sessões de Treinamento ao longo do
período do estudo então quem participou
Esse estudo foram 46 adultos idade média
de 32 anos ou média de idade né de 32
anos 20 homens e 26
mulheres todos os participantes não
possuíam condições de saúde conhecida
condições de doenças né e tinham uma
frequência de exercícios baixa nos se
meses anteriores ao estudo então essa
seleção permitiu avaliar de forma mais
precisa como a autorregulação da
intensidade impacta a Adesão indivíduos
que não tem hábito regular de exercitar
Então como é que foi conduzido Esse
estudo eles realizaram o ensaio
controlado randomizado de 8 semanas em
que todos os participantes se engajaram
em um programa de exercício de academia
as sessões de treino eram oferecidas A
cada dois ou três dias e os
participantes podiam optar por
participar ou não conforme a
conveniência então Cada sessão Durava
aproximadamente 60 minutos e era
conduzida por um personal trainer de
forma individual então a estrutura das
sessões
incluíam caminhada ou corrida de esteira
por 15 minutos seguido por treinamento
de resistência ou seja força né
musculação com cinco exercícios duas
séries cada ciclismo estacionário por 15
minutos e finalizando com
alongamentos Metade dos participantes
foi instruído a autorre regular a
intensidade dos exercícios com base no
prazer e na tolerância enquanto a outra
metade instruções padronizadas sobre a
intensidade a ser mantida Então essa
divisão permitiu comparar diretamente os
efeitos da autorregulação com métodos
tradicionais de prescrição de exercício
Então os resultados foram os
seguintes os participantes que autorre
regularam a intensidade dos exercícios
com base no prazer compareceram
77% mais sessões de treino totalizando
em média 14,4 sessões ao longo do estudo
em em contraste o grupo de controle que
recebeu instruções padronizadas
participou de apenas 8,1 sessões em
média olha só a diferença muito grande
né isso representa uma diferença muito
significativa na adesão ao programa de
exercícios entre os dois grupos Além
disso o grupo que autorre regulou a
intensidade relatou níveis mais altos de
prazer durante as primeiras três sessões
de exercício tanto a antecipação quanto
a lembrança do Prazer associada aos
treinos foram superior
nesse grupo em comparação grupo de
controle então esses resultados sugerem
que a percepção positiva do exercício
está fortemente ligada à frequência com
que as pessoas se exercitam então a
importância da atividade física para a
saúde vocês sabem muito bem que é
inegável trazendo
benefícios múltiplos vão desde a redução
do risco de doenças cardiovasculares a
também redução do diabetes tipo 2 até a
melhora do humor da qualidade do sono
no entanto apenas cerca de 20% dos
adultos cumprem as diretrizes de
atividade física recomendadas né devido
em grande parte a falta de movimentação
e Prazer nos exercícios Então esse
estudo destaca que aumentar o prazer
durante os treinos pode ser uma
estratégia eficaz para melhorar a Adesão
aos programas de exercícios ao permitir
que as pessoas ajustem a intensidade dos
exercícios conforme seu conforto e
Prazer torna-se mais fácil transformar a
atividade física em um hábito
sustentável Além disso outras
estratégias complementares como
encontrar exercício que você goste
treinar em grupo variar os tipos de
exercícios ouvir música agradável e se
exercitar em ambientes estimulantes
também podem contribuir para aumentar a
motivação e a consistência dos
resultados dos
treinos tá então é um estudo
interessante mostrando que mesmo vocês
que não gostam de se exercitar vocês
podem adaptar o exercício ao seu estilo
e tornar então isso um hábito recorrente
e não parar de fazer atividade
tá tem mais perguntas do Eliseu aqui o
Eliseu apareceu hoje né semana passada
Eliseu tava doente ele não
apareceu você concorda que a pressão 12
por 8 é alta normal não é normal Eliseu
Mas 11 por 7 é um melhor tá o artigo
sobre melatonina é show também gostei
Fernando para ajudar no sono só para
visar poderia associar triptofano
poderia ou Gaba Eu geralmente eu passo
esses vários outros elementos junto com
melatonina até esqueci de comentar
isso eu não uso melatonina isolado é
muito difícil eu uso melatonina
associado a ervas
calmantes uso muito lanina muito taurina
muo glicina lisina uso gaba uso
triptofano
tá é muito difícil usar melatonina
isolada praticamente eu não uso isolado
É verdade que existe um remédio que mata
o vírus HIV contanto que a pessoa tomou
esse remédio até 24 horas sim são os
antivirais né por isso que quando a
pessoa se fura o dedo com s contaminado
ela deve tomar um esquema profilático
quando eu tava na residência Cia geral
me fori uma vez com agulha D paciente
HIV e eu tive que tomar os antivirais da
época lá né então é verdade sim tá
previne a a pessoa pegar o HIV mas isso
Geralmente se faz quando
você se furou né com uma pessoa
sabidamente com HIV você não vai fazer
isso depois de relação sexual
especialmente se você não sabe que a
pessoa se bem que tem sim tem alguns
parceiros ou parceiras de gente com HIV
que tomam Às vezes o antiviral Se bem
que quem toma antiviral geralmente aí é
o parceiro que tá com a doença
diagnosticada Boa noite
Evanete e Trip toofan Toma também 3
horas antes de dormir pode tomar J com a
melatonina Sim 3 horas a gente
dormir estamos 46 minutos de
transmissão eu vou sair com 50 tá
pessoal então vocês têm 4 minutos ainda
para perguntar mais alguma
coisa então então só para quem não
entendeu ainda Eu não vou parar o canal
do YouTube tá eu fiz aquele vídeo
falando que ia terminar o canal do
YouTube mas no sentido que eu vou
reduzir
muito a
produção Ok e vou parar de me preocupar
com a quantidade de views que tem nesse
canal mas para vocês como eu falei no
áudio que eu mandei no grupo que talvez
não foi todo mundo que assistiu que
ouviu o áudio para vocês não mudam nada
vocês continuam com as lives semanais
Eduardo Ramos Dr Ronal disse que a
musculação é a melhor atividade para
retardar e reverter o envelhecimento tem
que fazer os dois musculação e o
aeróbico tá eu gosto mais da musculação
mas tem que fazer os dois mas se não me
engano ele orienta fazer No Limiar da
Resistência é mas isso é o que se faz
para hipertrofia tá ele não tá contando
nenhuma novidade aqui não mas veja bem
se a pessoa dê a musculação e ela não
gosta de fazer até o Limiar que eu como
eu faço né eu faço até ter a fadiga
muscular né até ter a falha muscular é
melhor que ela faça sem falha do que não
fazer nada concorda esse que é o ponto
por isso que o estudo é interessante
quando triptofano entra no organismo Ele
faz o corpo produzir melatonina sim ele
pode ser o precursor da melatonina
especialmente Se você estiver no escuro
tá eh durante o dia o triptofano
geralmente
vira serotonina n à noite ele vira
melatonina bem pessoal Falta 2 minutos
pra gente encerrar
então se você toma melatonina mais
triptofan você não estará tomando
melatonina demais não é só você tomar
por volta de 3
MG porque você viu pelo estudo que a
dose segura É até 10 mg de melatonina né
então não vai dar esse essa intoxicação
que você tá falando não porque o
triptofano Digamos que 500 mg de
triptofano vai
equivaler muito grosseiramente 1 MG de
melatonina
tá doutor pode tomar vários óticos ao
mesmo tempo pode pode sim Evanete varas
cepas né você quer dizer né na verdade a
maior parte dos produtos que tem no
mercado São combinações de cepas né não
são uma Cepa só não ok
de nada Evanete de
nada Bem pessoal vamos então nos
preparar para encerrar a Live tá alguma
última pergunta temos um minuto para
encerrar a
Live vocês estão acessando os documentos
com os resumos das lives e também estão
usando as marcações dos vídeos porque
deu um trabalho do cão fazer aquilo lá e
eu fiquei
postergando começar esse trabalho porque
eu sabia que ia dar trabalho né e não
sei não tô vendo o feedback de
vocês vocês estão usando o documento do
resumo das lives ou não Inclusive eu
tenho que ir lá e acrescentar as últimas
duas lives lá
bem eh eu vou esperar que vocês
respondam por favor lá no no grupo do
WhatsApp tá porque eu vou encerrar por
agora aqui muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês um grande abraço
uma excelente semana ver antes de eu
sair José Eduardo tá perguntando onde
vejo os documentos eu divulguei no grupo
lá eu divulguei lá no
grupo ó o Fernando tá falando aqui ó ali
pesquis top fando faz um favor joga o
link de novo lá no grupo que eu fixo
depois faz gentileza por favor então tá
pessoal um abraço para vocês até a
próxima